History is filled with stories of eccentric
people whose lives were littered with astonishing
and sometimes improbable stories.
Edward Hughes Ball Hughes (that was his real
name) was one such individual- a man who spent
money so erratically that he came to be known
by the rather fitting moniker of Golden Ball
Hughes or more simple, The Golden Ball.
Born in 1798 to a relatively well off family,
Edward Hughes Ball enjoyed the finest education
money could provide, studying at both Eton
and Trinity College in Cambridge.
He also enjoyed a brief stint in the army
shortly after leaving college, serving with
the 7th Queen’s Own Hussars right up until
1819 when he heard the news that a distant
uncle on his mother’s side had sadly passed
away.
As it turns out, this uncle had left the young
man his entire estate, comprising of two homes
in London, an estate in Essex, and approximately
£600,000, or roughly £50 million today ($66
million).
The finances from this inheritance were put
into a trust to be doled out to Edward to
the tune of around £40,000 per year (the
modern equivalent of about three or four million
pounds).
Around this time, Edward legally changed his
name from Edward Ball Hughes to Edward Hughes
Ball Hughes as a nod to the uncle who’d
left him his hard earned fortune, one Admiral
Sir Edward Hughes.
Soon after inheriting the money his uncle
had painstakingly accumulated over his lifetime,
Edward Hughes Ball Hughes set about transforming
himself into the epitome of an English dandy
by spending his inheritance as fast and as
frivolously as he could.
Known for being extraordinarily handsome,
with an enormous fortune now at his disposal,
Hughes easily assimilated himself into the
upper classes of society, peacocking his way
onto the radar of the rich and powerful of
the nation at every opportunity possible.
Found at virtually any party of note near
London, Hughes, dressed to the nines, would
roll up to balls and galas in a custom made
chocolate coloured coach pulled by matching
horses, invariably with a beautiful young
woman on each arm.
Hughes’ flamboyant dress sense and overwhelmingly
affable personality saw him become popular
with the self-styled aristocratic dandies
of the day, with his peers affectionately
referring to him as “Golden Ball Hughes”
in reference to his fabulous wealth.
Despite his popularity, many preyed on Hughes’
seemingly obliviousness to the value of money
and his love of gambling to fleece the young
fop at every turn.
He was even known to be willing to bet many
thousands of pounds on things as innocent
as a single flip of a coin.
Hughes was such a naive gambler, and so well
liked, that in 1824 someone took it upon him
or herself to warn the hapless rake about
ne’er do wells who were trying to take his
money, going as far as printing a pamphlet
and sending it to him, which stated, among
other things:
Another observation I must make – you were
chosen a member of White’s Club-house on
the day of your marriage.
Listen, Sir, a WARNING VOICE; there are THREE
members of THAT Club who have ALREADY marked
you as a victim to combinations you cannot
detect, and to skill you are unable to oppose.
Ruin will follow your steps THERE; you cannot
escape.
If you play in private, or at subscription
houses you devote yourself to inevitable destruction,
and your whole family to beggary.
In these slaughter houses, carcass butchers
of rank and title will knock down your whole
fortune in one night…
The day after the pamphlet arrived, Hughes
went to that same gambling club and, indeed,
lost a relatively large percentage of his
fortune in one night, a sum of close to £45,000
(about £4 million today).
Thanks to his massive and frequent losses,
Hughes’ was, at least according to one contemporary’s
seemingly ironic account, “perhaps the greatest
gambler of his day”.
Maria-MercandottiShortly before this gambling
debacle, in 1823, the 25 year old Hughes became
infatuated with a 16 year old Spanish dancer
called Maria Mercandotti.
According to a contemporary article in The
London Gazette,
Mercandotti, who had been gaining ground till
she was at the height of public favour, on
the first night of this ballet (the 8th of
March) took the part of the king’s page
in this performance, and looked and danced
it admirably.
Among the number of hearts on whom the bewitching
eyes of the fair Spaniard had made an impression,
was that of a gentleman well known as a man
of wealth and fashion, Mr. Hughes Ball.
This worshiper, like many others, had long
and assiduously devoted his attentions to
Mercandotti; but she was one of those rare
examples that now and then occur to ornament
the female biography of the stage, who, in
a situation of all others the most trying
to the best virtues of woman, preserve unsullied
the integrity of their reputation.
Nevertheless, a few months later, with a packed
house set to see the young starlet perform,
she mysteriously didn’t show up, forcing
the manager to tell the audience the show
was canceled, ostensibly because Mercandotti
was sick.
However, in The London Gazette report, it
was later noted, “that Mercandotti had a
more agreeable cause of absence than ill health,
and that she accepted the hand offered to
her, at length, by Mr. Ball.”
When this fact emerged, noted English author
William Harrison Ainsworth reportedly quipped:
“The damsel is gone, and no wonder at all
that, bred to the dance, she has gone to the
Ball.”
Less than a year after marrying Mercandotti,
Hughes purchased a 3,233 acre property known
as the Oatlands Estate from the Duke of York
where he and his new wife enjoyed the finer
things in life like hunting and banqueting.
Now, you probably think that we mean that
the pair did those activities separately,
but this is the Golden Ball we’re talking
about.
Hughes found a way to combine the two endeavours,
hiring a veritable army of servants to follow
him on his hunts carrying food, wine, spare
guns and an entire wardrobe so he could change
and hold a feast whenever he got bored with
the hunt.
Legal difficulties meant that Hughes didn’t
technically own Oatlands for three years after
he’d moved in because of an issue of the
ownership of a portion of the property from
a previous sale in the late 18th century.
In 1827, Hughes eventually got so annoyed
that he demanded his lawyers simply ignore
any objections to the sale using the age-old
tactic of throwing money at his problem until
it went away.
By this point, the Duke of York had died and
the sale was able to be completed without
much more delay, to the tune of about £145,000
(about £14,000,000 today).
A year after the sale was completed, the Golden
Ball ran out of gold and the property once
again went up for sale.
At the same time, Hughes fled the country
in the wake of the revelation that he’d
inadvertently gambled away nearly his entire
fortune.
In one of the only sound financial moves of
his life, Hughes wisely left control of his
affairs to the infinitely more capable hands
of his solicitors, Frere and Forster, who
also took over management of the Oatlands
Estate, even managing to turn a profit from
it.
Nevertheless, Hughes’ debts were such that,
despite the estate now being profitable, they
were forced to divide it up and sell it off
piece by piece to hold his creditors at bay.
At the same time they were securing Hughes’
financial future, his solicitors pleaded with
him to live within his means, agreeing to
send him an allowance equivalent in modern
times to several thousand pounds per week.
This paltry amount apparently wasn’t sufficient
and Hughes racked up even more debt by gambling
and spending exorbitant amounts on food, wine,
and clothing while in France.
To be fair, he was technically on vacation…
No doubt seeing the writing on the wall, or
perhaps not happy with the change in lifestyle
Hughes’ diminishing funds afforded, Mercandotti
divorced him in 1839 in search of better prospects.
Even after his financial situation was once
again secured thanks to the work of Frere
and Forster, Hughes never returned to England,
though seemingly did learn his lesson, living
a “quiet” life, by his standards at least,
in Paris where he had three children with
one Eliza Breugnot Momborne and later two
children with Anne Henriette de Dauvet in
the 1850s.
Hughes died in 1863 at the age of 65, leaving
behind an estate worth a little over £30,000
or about £3 million today.
While this isn’t exactly a figure to be
sniffed at, it’s almost nothing compared
to the enormous sum he once had as his inheritance,
an estate that even with mediocre management
should have seen him living lavishly, but
still managing to increase his net worth.